I want everybody to know that I'm
innocent
I've accompanied six human beings to
execution Richard would be the seventh
man is unbelievably decent I mean he
just really is hello I'm Ian woods and
you're listening to another dead man
walking over the next five episodes I
want to tell you why I've spent the past
few months chatting on the phone with a
man on death row in America he says he's
innocent we'll investigate whether
there's been a miscarriage of justice
state of Oklahoma gave life to the
lethal injection process I would support
hanging or beheading or whatever it
would take we hear from those who want
to execute him and from his closest
friends and family as the date fast
approaches
richard wants you to be a witness at his
execution i was driving my car with a
phone call on the speaker when I got the
unexpected invitation in 30 years as a
journalist I'd never been asked to
witness someone's death needless to say
it got my attention
at first the strongest emotion was
revulsion
then came the dark sense of exhilaration
which acts as a fuel for reporters when
we find an interesting story the man
facing the death penalty is Richard
Glossip he's 52 and has spent the past
18 years in jail in Oklahoma
everyone police lawyers the jury and his
trial except he didn't actually kill
anyone but the state of Oklahoma is
intent on killing him and refuses to
listen to his ongoing pleas that was him
talking on sky news a couple of weeks
ago he calls me from prison regularly
but this was the first time we'd put him
live on air before I tell you more about
Richard Glossip I better explain where I
fit into his story and why he asked me
to be an official witness to his death
it was a quiet day in the sky newsroom a
few days after Christmas last year I was
reading a story from The Associated
Press about the death penalty in America
and had there been a steady fall in the
number of executions over recent years
I've always been fascinated by the
subject and during four years of skies
United States correspondent I had
reported on a few death penalty cases
such as that of the Washington sniper
but that afternoon with frankly nothing
better to do I looked online at the list
of upcoming executions in the United
States there were two the following
month the first was by a man who'd raped
and killed his girlfriend's baby
daughter I shuddered and moved on to the
next one next in line was Richard
Glossip he was due to die on January the
29th just over four weeks time the more
I read about the case the more
interested I became and I found a TV
interview Glossip had given a few weeks
earlier with Fox 25 in Oklahoma
I didn't commit this crime and there's
no doubt in my mind that I may die
because of this but I want everybody to
know that I'm innocent and to stand up
contact the governor and stop an
innocent man from being executed the
murder was in January 1997 the victim
was barry van Treece who owned a seedy
motel in oklahoma city it was used by
drug dealers and hookers Richard Glossip
was the manager and among the people who
worked there was a 19 year old called
Justin Sneed he was a drifter from Texas
and he did all jobs unpaid in return for
somewhere to stay Sneed was arrested and
questioned about the killing the audio
from his original police interview isn't
great quality but listen here as he
describes what happened if you couldn't
make that out Sneed admitted killing his
victim with a baseball bat before
throwing the weapon in a bin
incidentally the bat was never found so
the police had their killer and robbery
was thought to be the motive but Sneed
said that Richard Glossip
had put him up to it supposedly because
he feared Vann trees was about to fire
him from his job as manager Sneed agreed
to a plea deal with the district
attorney in return for implicating
Glossop he escaped a possible death
sentence he's now serving life in prison
Glossop refused to plead guilty to
murder he was convicted largely on
Snead's testimony and was sentenced to
death his attorney though was deemed to
be so incompetent that he was fired and
a retrial ordered it produced the same
result guilty they even offered me a
straight life sentence before my second
trial and I told him no at the clemency
hearing one of the panel asked the DA in
you know why did you offer him that deal
and both of them said well you know the
case wasn't that good it wasn't that
good because I didn't commit a crime the
reporter who interviewed him in prison
was Phil cross he's an experienced
investigative journalist I called him up
for a chat he was very helpful and a few
weeks later I was in Oklahoma and talked
to him about the case Richard is the
only inmate on Oklahoma's death row that
didn't actually kill somebody you've met
him
how'd he come across to you he came
across as very genuine very honest he
was soft-spoken when you talked to him
you know his eyes you know his eyes are
bright he makes really good eye contact
with you he expressed his remorse for
for what happened I mean even to the
point where you hear some people talk
about their their victims as well mr.
so-and-so or whatever he says I'm sorry
for what happened to Barry you know he
pretty still has that personalization to
him
I believe that he definitely believes in
his innocence I mean there's no sign
that he you know whether or not you know
it's true or not I mean he's come to the
point where he definitely believes it
because he really doesn't show any of
those signs of you know deception where
unions shifting your eyes or not showing
a motion or anything like that he really
comes off across this very genuine
before flying to Oklahoma had stopped
off in New York to meet the man who
suggested I watched the Richard Glossip
execution Kim Van Atta is a health care
professional specializing in child care
but he's become Glossop's best friend a
casual acquaintance who was then
Glossop's attorney had asked him to be
his pen pal based solely on the tenuous
connection that they all like the same
indie rock band guided by voices
vanitha had been reluctant but then
found himself drawn into the world of
death row prisoners I mean initially
started out he didn't know me I didn't
know him it was I look back at our old
letters and they're sort of semi-formal
you know it's like feeling each other
out and at that but within the course of
about six months a year it really
started to deepen and I think primarily
because the man is unbelievably decent I
mean he just really is what convinces
you that he's not guilty from the
beginning the motive that this man was
afraid of being fired so he was going to
offer someone $10,000 to kill the boss
I'm not sure if that would a allow him
to keep his job or be be particularly
beneficial to him I mean Richard had had
a number of jobs mostly in retail food
you know in food management he had run
motels before the jobs weren't that few
and far between he could have gotten
another job fairly easily and if you
look at his work history that's clear he
never was fired from any jobs he had
never been in trouble with the law
that's the other thing that that got me
there was another reason I went to see
Kim Van Atta that day did call her side
now he'd arranged that Richard Glossip
would phone him while I was in his
apartment that way I could talk to him -
this was the first of many conversations
I've had with him Richard just try to
explain to us why people should believe
your story now when as you know to
juries didn't believe you and various
judges haven't believed you
why do you think other people should
listen to what you're saying as well as
the serious business of his execution
which at this point was scheduled to
happen just three days later we also
talked about how he spends much of his
time watching television free public
channels like he has access to survive
on a diet of old BB
are you being served his own personal
favorite and you're able to you're able
to laugh even at this dark time we
wrapped up the interview pretty quickly
there was a massive Blizzard blowing
into New York and Kim and I had separate
flights the cash to get to Oklahoma
we shared a cab to JFK and just made it
out before snow closed the airport by
contrast Oklahoma City was unseasonable
warm the Sun was shining out of a clear
blue sky when we arrived a film at the
Oklahoma State Capitol building I was
there for a news conference and my first
meeting with another key figure in the
Richard Glossip case hello I'm glad I'm
sister Helen Prejean
she's a well-known figure in the u.s.
anti-death-penalty movement but her
story was made even more famous because
the book she wrote was turned into a
film dead man walking he was put in a
request to be the spiritual advisor to
Matthew Poncelet this boy is to be
executed in six
days do you know what you getting into
Suzan sound and won the Best Actress
Oscar for her portrayal of the nun from
New Orleans who accompanied condemned
men to their deaths
sister Helen is now 76 she hasn't been
to an execution for years but when
Richard gossip wrote to her she read
more about his case and agreed to help I
want to just say that truly the eyes of
the world are on Oklahoma today and when
I say the world is looking at us I have
word that Pope Francis is very aware and
following closely the situation that we
are in here in Oklahoma and he is
praying for all involved the news
conference was to plead for a stay of
execution from the governor of Oklahoma
Mary Fallon and at that stage there was
real cause for optimism a few days
earlier the United States Supreme Court
had agreed to hear arguments against one
of the drugs used in the lethal
injection process the case had been
brought by Glossop and two other
prisoners in Oklahoma who would you to
be executed in the coming weeks but
crucially the court hadn't ruled those
executions should be put on hold until
after the Supreme Court justices had
deliberated one of those attending the
news conference was the Reverend Adam
leathers for those of us who profess a
Christian faith we cannot believe that
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ who was
a victim of the death penalty himself
and who revoked an eye for an eye
we cannot believe he would tolerate the
death penalty there's a lot of
church-going people in this state and
elsewhere who would describe themselves
as being supporters of the death penalty
do you think it is compatible to be a
Christian and a supporter of the death
penalty it's hard to be to say I'm
following Jesus and the beatitude and
blessed of the poor and to say that you
believe in the death penalty and
government killing their people it's an
important question because Christianity
and the death penalty are both pretty
popular in Oklahoma
sister Helen and her supporters then
walked the short distance to the
governor's office to hand over a
petition with thousands of signatures
around 5:30 a.m. it was thirty thousand
831 but I know for a fact every time you
look at tire yeah remember I told you
about that day back in December when I
first looked at the list of upcoming
executions Charles Warner the first guy
who'd raped and killed the baby girl had
already been put to death inside
Oklahoma State Penitentiary
it was the first time Oklahoma had
carried out an execution since
attracting international headlines seven
months earlier Clayton Lockett was sent
to his death last night but shortly
after his execution went seriously wrong
the prison director was having to
explain what had happened there was some
concern at that time that the drug 6:23
the execution started 6:39 is when they
closed the curtains on us Lockett took
nearly three quarters of an hour to die
it sparked a fresh debate on the use of
lethal injection and Richard Glossip
was now the central character in that
debate he was due to die next next week
how gossip came within 24 hours of
execution how his case then moved to
Washington DC and why America is running
out of the drugs needed to kill the men
and women on death row